So now we will start the
second chapter of Chemistry from today. This is the
acid base and salts.
Acids are those substances which have an acidic
solution. What is their
action solution? Sour tu test
like here if you see it.  It is an
acid for us, it is our base,
because if it is a base, then washing
soda will neutralize it. Washing soda is an example of a base.
Now you will say, how is this washing soda of ours, it is used
in washing,
right, similarly, baking soda is used in
cakes.  To make any fluffy item,
absolutely co2 is being released, you can
see that here it turns the blue litmus paper
red and whatever is the base, it turns the red
litmus paper blue.